giuliani just put basically his career
on the line
his entire yeah i mean what would you
call his legacy
everything that he's done is now on the
line he said that there was
this there was illegal stuff on there
involved
now we're getting into the the bad stuff
let's let's go for it let's let's let's
pull it up
from the examiner examiner rudy giuliani
says he sent
alleged sexually explicit materials
involving underage girls from hunter
biden to delaware police
this is the examiner so so here's what
we know giuliani
said he did it and is that news in and
of itself
well just to the news reached out to the
police and the police said we did
forward the materials to right you know
to the fbi or
i'm sorry the state the state department
of justice
does it mean we have evidence no doesn't
mean hunter biden is guilty no he's
innocent until proven guilty and i mean
i haven't seen anything
yeah now the challenge with this is no
one's going to publish any explicit
photographs of an underage it's not
going to happen
so the question now is like what do we
do
13 days out from an election with this
material
so it's it's there i mean there's let me
read a little bit they say rudy giuliani
said on tuesday that he shared allegedly
explicit materials involving underage
girls from hunter biden with police
in delaware the text messages and photos
discussed by giuliani a personal lawyer
to president trump
and former new york city mayor appear to
have been found in a laptop hard drive
that purportedly belonged to hunter
biden
blah blah blah those computer materials
are already in possession of the fbi
quote there's a text message to hunter's
father in which he says the following
and he's discussing his sister-in-law
who for quite some time was his lover
giuliani told newsmax setting up the
background for the exchange he says
she told my therapist that i was
sexually inappropriate
this would be with an unnamed 14 year
old girl and that's
what biden was apparently saying now i
want to stop there
by hunter is saying to joe she accused
me of this
that doesn't mean he was accused of it
doesn't mean i there's any photos so we
don't know for sure
and that's that's what giuliani has has
actually shown
right giuliani if there was photos he's
not going to hold up a photograph yeah
for a camera so it it is a a conundrum
but i'll tell you this
i don't believe no matter what you think
of rudy giuliani
he's fabricating these things i'm
willing to bet he gave some stuff to the
police now the question is how serious
is it we won't know
right and here's the thing too like the
idea that it's fabricated right even
setting aside anyone's personal feelings
about giuliani that would be a felony
and not just any felony like that would
catch him in an enormous amount of very
very public
legal penalty and legal problem and so
the idea that he would make all this up
and fabricate it like somebody
he's got to be smart enough to know that
if he does that someone will find it
someone will find it in the end
right but think about this you know
james o'keefe brought this up that it
feels like the new york times and these
media outlets are smearing him with
outright and obvious lies
yeah because we got two weeks to the
election so just letter up and deal with
it later
exactly because that's the thing like if
you're like if you
want whether you're in the media or
whether you're in politics or whatever
it is if you want biden to win
now is not the time to be curious right
you don't want to be curious about any
of this and so i think
you know there's there's a little bit of
a the ends justify the means i think
going on in a lot of people's heads
where
even the idea like let's say let's say
and i don't think this will happen but
let's say it all comes out to be bunk
it's all fake
if you're a journalist at the new york
times or cnn and you start poking around
and start raising the profile of this
thing
and it actually is disinformation again
no evidence that it is but in these
people's minds if it's this information
then they're pulling it they're doing
what comey did last cycle right they're
giving evidence to
they're giving weight to people to vote
against biden
in the run-up to an election and they're
too scared to even touch it i think if
you
if if if they report on it in any
capacity
yep it's out there exactly and you're
not going to reach every single person
so
the media being a at this point an
apparatus at the democratic party
is just shutting up whereas an actual
news outlet is going to be like i don't
care when it is
right i don't care what what's happening
let's talk about the story
so my my position has been basically is
this
dirty politics oh you betcha they are
releasing this information in october on
purpose
they want to help trump win does that
mean hunter biden is innocent
no this is pretty damning information
and joe biden seems to be involved in
these like pay-for-play kind of things
i think they wait until the very last
minute to influence an election
because that's what they do that's what
hillary clinton was doing with oppo
research in the steel dossier it's dirty
politics
now what are we as citizens supposed to
do when we find out at the very last in
the 11th hour
that joe biden might be selling his name
using his son as an intermediary to
bypass
laws potentially a loophole oh man
don't vote for him i guess that's the
first thing you do and so so there's a
question of
is it is it good that they waited this
long so that it's fresh in our minds
because if they publish this information
months ago everyone won't forget about
it yeah it'd be buried by now okay
so it wouldn't come up and stuff yeah
yeah and you know right like no debate
moderator is going to touch it it's
going to go
it's going to go down the memory hole
and we're all going to forget about it
now trump's going to bring it up
tomorrow
they're going to be like mr trump uh we
want to talk to you about black lives
matter and he's going to go
hunter biden's laptop has photographs of
underage
the problem is if he did that doesn't
have anything to joe
my opinion if hunter is a scheming you
know no no
dirty underage girl doing guy
it's not joe biden yes but if biden's
involved with
barisma that's a problem no the cefc's
is the bigger deal in my opinion
that's the chinese chinese energy they
were under my understanding is the thing
about barisma is that
they they've tried to debunk this to an
up to the uptick degree it's like
you know oh joe was doing it because the
international community thought choking
was was bad or whatever and i'm like
yeah okay how about the china email i
saw this one dude i know he posted
joe biden uh the hunter joe biden may be
meeting an executive from ukrainian
company company is the like
worst october surprise i've ever seen
and it's responded with
the uh the best i've seen was the email
indicating joe biden was using his son
as an intermediary to receive chinese
equity
you know as through a loophole
essentially right that's the big that's
the big that's the crazy
but i'll tell you what if joe biden came
out
when this email dropped in these emails
dropped when the laptop dropped and the
emails dropped
and he said i think everybody knows at
this point that i have a troubled son
and i think many people in this country
have dealt with addiction and
and struggled through that they
understand what it's like to have a
loved one who does as well
and i would respect you know ask for
privacy and then actually
if he actually was honest addressed it
wasn't angry and snapping no you're
lying
you're smearing me raw yeah and he
actually just he owned up to it
it would have worked in his favor agreed
he would have been a sympathetic dad
who's got his troubled kid that he's
trying and you know what man
he really could have played it up if he
said it uh hunter is his only son now
right because after both pastor bo pass
yeah if he
said i had a son bo biden who passed it
was cancer i believe right yeah yeah
and he says and now my my only child has
these addictions these problems and is
struggling
and i'm doing everything in my power to
to keep him
safe and and protect him and it's
causing great
you know struggles through my family and
i will do anything for my son that would
have been sympathetic
people would have been like this poor
guy this poor guy and there's so many
people in this country who probably can
sympathize with having a messed up kid
yeah but knowing they still love him and
will do anything for him instead
what ended up happening with joe biden
is he snaps at reporters he refused to
take questions
and it makes it seem like he's the
mastermind using his son to make cash
yeah and bring you know and he's
obviously denigrating reporters too
right this happened
with bo what's his face from from cbs he
it would be one thing if he said hey you
know what that's not appropriate and
then jumped into what you
just mentioned right and talked about a
very unfortunately and tragically
american story about what it's like to
have a loved one who's battling
addiction
you're right like that's the sort of
thing that millions and millions and
millions of americans can
relate to in a deeply sympathetic way
but the fact is
he claims up he shuts down and he gets
mad at a reporter for even having the
gall
to ask and it does it makes it makes it
look like he's got something to hide
because the
like i think he does but i mean biden's
been in public life for 47 years he's
answered probably not lately but he's
answered tough questions in front of the
media he's been media trained
there's a super easy way to pivot and
the fact that he's not taking it as
someone seeking the highest office in
the land
it does smell bad well i i can say
there's one there's there's two
different ways to look at it one he's
lost it he's lost his edge also
i mean come on man the dude's 70s was he
78 now he's still 77
77 i don't know he's he's he's
uh he he doesn't have it anymore you
know speaking of things we're not
allowed to talk about right
what yeah no it's it's his mental health
and his son's emails
oh he's right off topic let me tell you
tara reid i want to talk about that oh
that's right
the cat rape allegedly sexually
assaulted assault
so listen listen now something i'm 34
and i skateboard all the time
and it's funny when like people comment
and they're like man tim for someone
your 30s you still got it and i'm like
dude when i was 19 i would jump off a
building and like bounce on the ground
and get back and be like yeah i'm 34 and
i'm not doing that i'm skating ramps
it's easier on the knees and stuff
amazing listen
um skateboarding is something you can do
really really well when you're into your
late teens and early 20s
and then when every skateboarder knows
when you're 30s you kind of chill out a
little bit but there are some pro
skaters who are still in their 50s and
they're still they're doing really
really well but we all understand how
sports works yeah how long do you play
football basketball for joe biden is 77
he's not sharp anymore he can't handle
this
so maybe he used to be able to handle
tough questions and now he can't
so he gets bits of you know what it is
when people's brains don't work and they
can't recall
and they and and they feel constrained
by their lack of ability they get angry
they get angry right you see this with
men a lot yeah with dementia right with
dementia
yeah i can only imagine how frustrating
it is right to be like standing there
and you're like
think why can't i think why can't i what
do i say i'm just sick of this no
shut your mouth and in front of the
whole world too right it's not like he's
just a guy going about his life or
whatever he's also a plagiarist
like was it the 1988
presidential or something like that i
think it was 87 he dropped out because
he got caught plagiarizing
in his presidential bid did you see
took some words from a british
politician used him as his own and well
to reassure his staff he said listen
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
so good classic that's good oh back when
stand-up was good but but then didn't
biden recently
no no he's been yeah he's he's been
plagiarizing a lot wasn't there
something recently he did yeah
i was i'm scratching my brain for that
too well so
yeah oh right let me go back to the
first point i was trying to make about
the emails is that
he may just be dull and unable and it's
really frustrating
to like not be able to do it anymore
sure but the other thing may be
that he's in on it and he knows what he
was doing and he's freaking out
yeah so he's getting asked he's like
shut your mouth yeah and i mean that's
the thing too like it's
it looks like i think that obviously it
all looks bad
but can you imagine if anyone in good
faith in the media or whatever it is
if they actually thought that this was
something that was that was a non-story
if they actually spent some time to to
look into it i think one of the reasons
it looks so bad and him looking
frustrated looks so bad is
everyone is saying don't look don't look
in the corner don't look in the corner
and so what are your eyes going to do
they're going to drive
like there's nothing else for them to do
and so when you have this this concerted
effort around it
to make sure that no one is looking at
this thing that like i don't know it's
the 800-pound elephant in the room but
you know you know what the media is
looking at right now
what rudy giuliani tucking in his shirt
oh yeah they're trying to smear giuliani
yeah this is this is a distraction
amazing the russia thing fell apart
that's why so
here's what's fascinating there's
illicit uh
illicitly obtained footage of giuliani
and there's a photo
that was published where he's leaning
back on a bed with his hand like
partially down his pants
and and i was reading the story and it
said because these news outlets want
to insinuate something but they struggle
to because they'll get sued
and it said giuliani laid back and
fiddled with his untucked shirt
as if to imply what the photos make it
look they're trying to make it seem like
giuliani got caught by
sasha baron cohen trying to like hook up
with a young journalist or something in
a hotel room
when in reality he was tucking in his
shirt he did an interview
they took the mic off and when they when
they mic you up they have to put it
through your shirt right yeah right
so he probably had to untuck a piece of
his shirt run the mic up the lapel
put on his jacket and then when they
took it down he was leaning back an old
fat man you know tucking your shirt in
then they used that to make it seem like
he was doing something else
so so so here's here's what's funny
giuliani says
i've got text messages here's an email
and they go well we don't know if this
is true
yeah and then sasha baron cohen goes i
am barat and here is giuliani and then
they're all like
everybody look at giuliani he's getting
naked or something
something yeah i mean it's the entire
media who just lectured us for a really
long time about how we have to wait for
things to shake out and wait for more
evidence to develop
or else it might be someone who is
deliberately trying to mislead us can
one can 100
jump the shark as soon as it becomes
convenient for them right and i think
this is why
that you know we brought up the steel
dossier earlier i think this is why a
lot of conservatives look at the these
say hey don't don't look at the man
behind the behind the curtain and say
you've never you've never cared about
this before when have you once
showed even a tiny tiny modicum
of reservation before accepting a story
when it's helpful and convenient for you
and they just did it again they're in
the middle of ignoring another story
that matters
and they jump the shark on something
else that is very clearly tied to it you
know what i think
like the the democratic party and the
establishment
left it seems to be a chicken running
around with its head cut off right
and i don't think anybody cut its head
off like trump didn't do it
trump came because they were frantic and
and spread
like you know [ __ ] yeah i think maybe
they just uh
the establishment politics of this
country just eventually
lost its will and strength and maybe
maybe it's hillary clinton's fault
yeah like maybe instead of the democrats
finding a strong charismatic leader to
carry the party forward
hillary demanded it and she wasn't the
person who was supposed to lead them
and that resulted in a substantive
weakening of what the left was
and so the reason i bring this up is i'm
i'm thinking about sasha baron cohen and
what he's trying to do
and i think 10 years ago like when was
borat when it first come out
yeah it was look back in the days of jon
stewart
you had very smart liberal individuals
who in good faith
mocked things that were ludicrous and
you know jon stewart
like we might i mentioned before the
show but he's even praised project
veritas back
back in the day and james o'keefe is i
think i think he may have tweeted about
it at some point
james uh uh john stewart was like they
did good journalism they exposed this
and he even showed like the acorn
investigation veritas did and he was
like
tell me this does not get worse and he
uncritically was showing veritas like
this is
this is this is amazing stuff yeah today
after jon stewart leaves after obama you
know leaves in 2016
there is a power vacuum in the
democratic party and is the
establishment left in this country where
there's no
charisma anymore right hillary clinton
certainly didn't have any
and then they started creating all of
these like plastic versions of jon
stewart so john oliver jordan clepper
samantha bee trevor noah they do not
understand
what made the daily show fun and
interesting and exciting
right so now what you get is and looking
back to sacha baron cohen it
it's i don't know make fun of
conservatives
i guess and people like it so what's
happened is they've created this
political structure
based on people with like low
information individuals
who don't do research who don't read
news who literally get their news from
trevor noah or john oliver
when people were getting their news from
jon stewart it was kind of bad
but it wasn't that bad because jon
stewart still would like
show you veritas and uncritically like
can you believe this stuff
so you were getting your news in a fun
and interesting way where someone was
being funny
to replicate this b-tier individuals who
didn't have the charisma or talent of
someone like stuart
looked at his show and misunderstood
what made it interesting
and they said you know what he does he
makes fun of conservatives
so you end up now with these like look
at john oliver i love this
john oliver when his show last week
tonight first started you know first
started airing when it first came out
it was always blowing up on reddit and
and getting you know upvoted crazy every
single time
and then one day it slowly started going
down and people were posting it less and
uploading it less
and i noticed in the comments people
were saying dude all of his jokes his
shows are the exact
same show with different proper nouns he
would do the exact same thing and that's
why the meme of current year little
timothy
it's current year because that's his he
had
they took one stewart joke yep wrote it
out and said
replace this and this and this and we
have a story yep and so that's what the
show was
so what happens when you create a bunch
of knock-off
plastic versions of what was once
charismatic and entertaining to the left
you get something boring and unwatchable
but the low information individuals who
like shows like big bang theory with
laugh tracks
no offense to big bang theory uh viewers
but it's like
it's you watch a show with a laugh track
because they tell you when to laugh
right
you watch john oliver because he tells
you when the joke is because the joke is
at
the same point every single time right
you're not getting real information
anymore
and you know you're never going to be
the butt of the joke right and i think
that's one of the keys for someone like
oliver in a way that stuart like
he he was always happy to be a circular
firing squad he'd take shots and anyone
he'd take shots himself whatever it is
but i think one of the reason why so
many people particularly right now when
things are really scary for a lot on the
left
are so drawn to a format like that is
they are always the good and righteous
one
and the person being laughed at is
always someone else whom they don't like
and honestly at the end
they probably don't know i think one of
the one of my favorite anecdotes that i
always come back to is there was a
journalist who did an interview with
other journalists about the number of
people who they knew who owned a ford
f-150
the what the biggest selling car in the
country and they didn't know anybody
they didn't know anybody it was like it
was like it was like one in 15
journalists or something knew someone
who had an f-150
whereas everyday americans it's like
one-on-one right and so when you've got
this
a small and now narrowing group of
people who are all laughing at the same
joke over and over again
within what is essentially a coddled
safe space where they know it's never
going to be them nothing they do could
ever be wrong
it becomes like it's comfort food for
them rather than something that's
entertaining
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you